my thing is this is is
if a man doesn't want to marry you then
he hasn't got good intention for you
long term that's what I believe you
don't think so when men women are paid
to leave the contract it's such a bad
contract nowadays where women are
incentivized to leave so like honestly I
think men have good reason not to want
to get married nowadays no I understand
that but if we if we talk about the
family home and we know about it we know
about all the statistics and and you
know being a two-parent home and having
a father that's in the home like like if
you really care about your family as a
man you would do certain things we also
know that there's certain certain
protections that be marriage does for
your wife as well and does for your
family so I just think ultimately
um if someone loves you that much
they're going to want to make the
ultimate sacrifice and commitment to you
commit with marriage yeah so let me live
with a with a 50 40 divorce rate where
she can leave take half and take your
kids you don't you don't think that some
men want traditional outcomes but
marriage just isn't on the table for
them